وزراء والطاقه الاوروبيون يناقشون التوافق
على سقف لاسعار الغاز بعد فشلهم في التوسل
الى اتفاق خلال الاشهر الاربعه الماضيه
اسعار الغاز ب
188 يوم مشيره الى ان عدد الدول المطالبه
بسقف منخفض للاسعار ترتفع الى 16 دوله في
مكانه عشر دوله 10 دوله الاسبوع الماضي
يشهد الملف توترا بعد ارتفاع عدد دول
المطالبه بتخفيض سقف الاسعار الى ما دون
المئتي يورو للميغوات في الساعه الى 16
بعد ان كانت اثنتا عشره دوله في الاسبوع
الماضي
الاتحاد الاوروبي ادى الى زياده في
الاستهلاك
سامسونج
سقف الاسعار قد اصبح في متناول اليد
ويتطلب تنازله من الجميع
اليوم في حدوث اتفاق خلال اجتماعي وزراء
طاقه الاوروبيين بشان ملف وضع السقف
لاسعار الغاز وان هناك احتياطات وضعت في
الاعتبار بسبب مخاوف في بعض الدول من
تاثير ذلك على الامداده
كبيرا بذل خلال الايام الماضيه من اجل
التوافق
توديو علينا الاتفاق اليوم على اليه ستحمل
منازل والشركات الاوروبيه من التاثر
بارتفاع اسعار الغاز كما حدث خلال الصيف
الماضي اعتقد ان هذه القطاعات تتوقع منا
ان نتحرك ولا ارى اي سبب لعدم التمكن من
الاتفاق اليوم لذلك يجب ان لا يوقفنا شيء
عن ذلك ونظرا لان القاده طلب القيام بذلك
يوم الخميس الماضي في اجتماعهم انا على
علم بان عدد من الدول تشعر بالقلق بشان
الغاز لذلك قمنا بوضع كثير من الضمانات
التي ستسمح لنا بالغاء تنشيط اليه سقف
الاسعار في حاله عدم عملها على سبيل
المثال في حاله وجود نقص في الغاز في دوله
او عده دول او في حال انخفاض الاسعار
منه مراسله الجزيره عبد الله الشامي عبد
الله عدد المؤيدين اللي سقف ادنى سعر
الغاز الروسي ارتفع هذا العدد من اثنتا من
اثنتا 10 دوله الى 16 دوله ما التغيير
الذي حدث
انما التغيير ربما هو ادراك الجميع انه اا
لابد من التوافق اليوم هذا الرقم مرده
ايضا الى ان الرئاسه تشيكيه التي همم تنهي
اعمالها في الاتحاد في اخر اسبوع من
الاجتماعات قررت وايضا بناء على تصريحات
نائب رئيس وزراء تشيكي ان الاتفاق سيكون
اليوم بالاغلبيه وليس بالاجماع كما هو
الحال عليه في كل قرارات الاتحاد الاوروبي
بالتالي ارتفاع هذا العدد اليوم 16 دوله
من اصل 27 يعطي هذه الاغلبيه الاغلبيه
التي تتجاوز ال 50% وهو ما سيعول عليه
المسلمون اليوم بالنظر لانه ربما رفع
السقف من 160 يورو كما كانت تطالب هذه
الدول الى 100 و88 لكل ثلاث ايام بدلا من
اسبوع كما كان معروض سابقا ربما شجع مزيد
من الدول على الانضمام الى هذه القائمه
وبالتالي مساله الاجماع التي بناءا عليها
اتخذ القرار اليوم الذي كما قال كل واصلين
سواء مفوضه الطاقه الاوروبيه او ممثل
رئاسه تشيكيه او غيرهم من الوراء هو
الفرصه الاخيره همم بالتالي ربما هو مادى
الى هذه الزياده لكن في ذات الوقت ايضا
كون اي تاجيل ليس في صالح احد بالنظر الى
ان الاتحاد يدخل رسميا حاله اجازه منذ
الاربعاء المقبل سيكون بناء عليه الضغط
اكثر على الوزراء الذين سيرون ان الاجتماع
هو الفرصه الاخيره في ذات الوقت ايضا هناك
محاوله لطم الدول التي ترفض هذا السقف
بسبب مسائل من مخاوف همم نقص الامدادات او
ربما شحهما سيصل الى الدول نعلم ان هذه
الدول ايضا تقلص عددها كانت ست دول العالم
اصبحت اربعه هي كل من الدنمارك والمجر
والمانيا وهولندا بدلا من سته كما كان
الحال عليه الاسبوع الماضي وبالتالي هذه
الدول هناك طبعا انا لها بان هذا الاجراء
اجراء التسعير هو اجراء مؤقت لن يكون هو
الحال عليه طوال العام المقبل عام 2023
انما هو
حتى شهر مارس في محاوله لطمانها بانها لن
تتاثر كدول بالنظر ايضا لان هذه الدول
الدول الصناعيه كبيره تحتاج الى الكثير من
الطاقه خصوصا كل من هولندا والمانيا التي
تعتمدان على همم على الغاز ومصادر الطاقه
عموما في جزء كبير من اا ما له علاقه
بالانتاج اليومي وغيرها وبالتالي هي
محاولات ربما ربما لتقريب جهه النظر في
اللحظات الاخيره بين هذه الدول عبد الله
الشامي من بروكسل شكرا